Speaker 1: David, is it true that Donald Trump
wore his pants backwards at that crazy speech
in North Carolina?
It is not true.
But listen, I understand what's going on.
Trump came up to the stage and we're going
to show a picture of it.
And his pants just looked strange.
There were weird creases on the front.
It almost looked like there were like there
was no zipper, like there was just a seam.
And there was speculation his pants were backwards
or it was some kind of a mermaid outfit or
he was wearing an elastic waistband.
And that's why there was no zipper.
I have to tell you, when I looked at it closely,
the wrinkles looked like Trump had just been
sitting and the pants are wrinkly.
And I do see what looks like a zipper crease,
although it's not as noticeable maybe as some
others would, I would imagine it to be.
And I didn't for a second think that Donald
Trump wore his pants backwards.
This was then looked at by Snopes and Snopes
did indeed determine no, Trump did not wear
his pants backward at the rally you asked.
So we watched the 90 minute speech and they
found that the photograph simply do not show
that Trump's pants were backwards.
Now, it's the funny thing to me about this
is, first of all, the idea that we many of
us would believe that Trump might wear his
pants backwards like that wouldn't be beyond
the realm of possibility.
I would believe it.
It just happened not to have been the case.
But the more interesting thing was how low
is the bar that a lot of the commentary is,
including my own on Twitter, when when I saw
this were essentially lizanne, the speech
was deranged.
Trump lied throughout it.
He told corrosive lies about democracy.
He did all of these things, but his pants
weren't on backwards.
And I think it was Lucas Grindley from The
Advocate, if I recall correctly, who responded
to me and said, this is how low the bar now
is, that we can say at least the guy's pants
were on straight, but no, his pants were forward.
I don't really care about Donald Trump's clothing.
I've never understood from a very just practical
perspective, a guy as wealthy as Trump claims
to be or as wealthy as Trump is.
They're not the same thing, but he's still
a wealthy guy.
How has no one gone to him and said, sir,
the full seat suit look is not in right now.
The tailored, slimmer fit looks and or maybe
they have.
And Trump doesn't look right in the slimmer
fit suits.
I've never understood how a guy this wealthy
has such terrible suits, but I know that Trump's
an older guy and that's a style that there
are other older men I know who still like
the full seat suit.
And that appears to be Trump.
But his pants were on forward as far as we
can tell.
David, now that we know more about the UFO
UAP revelations over the last month, are you
ready to say that the UFOs aren't aliens from
another planet?
Yeah, I mean, here's the thing.
I don't know how many times I have to say
this.
I've been asked this so many times when we
talk about an unidentified flying object or
a UAP.
We aren't implying that the default would
be if we aren't aware of what a thing is,
it's aliens from another planet.
And so after the 60 Minutes interview came
out with these claims about these UAP UFOs
that pilots had seen and some of the documents
that the government has released, and the
indication was we don't know what this is
because it doesn't match anything that is
ours.
And it's appearing to defy some of the constraints
of the physical world as we understand it,
and so on and so forth.
My first explanation isn't these are aliens
that came from somewhere else and nobody else
saw them arrive.
No other planet, no other country saw them
arrive to the planet.
But then our military pilots see, I don't
go to that.
The simplest explanations to me include some
aspect of this was distorted by the way that
it was filmed, which is one area of of study
that is being looked at and the idea that
certain camera lenses can make things look
as though they are moving in ways and that
speeds in which they actually aren't.
That's one aspect.
The other aspect would be these are foreign
elements of some kind from an adversary.
And so we are not.
We're being given limited information and
these this is say, you know, surveillance
of some kind from a from an adversary, the
third possibility would be this is U.S. stuff
that is so highly classified that what the
government has decided to do is to allow the
pilots to come out and say what they did,
but not go any further and just claim this
is not stuff the U.S. government is at least
publicly taking credit for when it actually
is some classified government program.
And then the fourth possibility, and this
is this is like the cynical one in some sense,
is that this is all a disinformation campaign
to make other countries see this stuff and
go, oh, man, is this do they have this at
the in the United States?
Is are these actually technologies that the
U.S. has we are way behind.
Let's try to reverse engineer this, for example.
And the idea is a disinformation campaign
to send other countries on a wild goose chase
to stuff that's simply CGI.
All of those possibilities strike me as far
more likely.
Again, just an Occam's razor.
What requires the fewest assumptions?
Those all strike me as far more likely than
these are aliens from some other part of the
universe that have visited us.
When I sort of said this is my position a
couple of weeks ago, I got 99 percent emails
from people saying, David, thank you.
This just makes sense.
This seems like the most plausible way to
understand what we've seen and a few people
saying, David, obviously these are aliens
from another planet and everybody's in on
the cover up and you're a part of being in
on the cover up.
Again, that requires lots of assumptions and
complexity.
So I tend to lean towards the simpler explanations
now for people who will write to me and say,
David, do you think that there are aliens?
I think that statistically it's likely there
is intelligent life elsewhere in the universe
other than Earth.
I just don't think this is it arriving.
Call me crazy.
Let me know your thoughts.
That's my best guess as to what this is as
of right now.